say you don't support reparations why
not not everybody suffered equally I
mean when you go into slavery
it's more much more complex than are
white people were the oppressors and
black people were the victims
if you if you dissect it you will find
there are about
3700 free bikes who own 12 000 slaves I
was born in 1937 doing the depression
everyone in my small low-income black
community
98 of the households had a man and a
woman raising children a big crisis
facing America is not racial it is a
moral and spiritual freefall that is
consuming our children what makes more
sense what that man is saying or what
you hear out of Lori Lightfoot or Pete
bootage or Joe Biden